oui
[Musique]
en 2014
un sociologue américaine racontait dans
le times l'expérience à laquelle elle
s'était livré tenté de cacher sa
grossesse au géant du web qui
collectionne des informations sont notre
vie privée
pour mieux nous vendre des produits en
nous inondant de publicité ciblée
comment elle fait pour y arriver
en ne mentionnant sa grossesse dans
aucun pourriels ou statue sur les
réseaux sociaux en demandant là sa
famille de garder le secret en ne
faisant aucune recherche lié à son état
sur le web et en payant tous ses achats
en argent comptant ou via un logiciel de
transaction anonyme
il faut savoir que pour les
publicitaires du web les données sur une
seule femme enceinte valent autant que
les données sur 200 personnes dans cette
même perspective google publie
régulièrement ses observations sur les
habitudes d'utilisation d'internet et
propose une section spécifique sur les
familles
de son côté facebook publié en 2016 son
bulletin mythe des karens et tout y
était les intérêts précis et les
interrogations des parents ou encore
formiez d'heures par jour il passe sur
le réseau social
une autre mine d'or d'informations pour
les publicitaires
[Musique]